Maxim welcome back to St Louis welcome
back to Grand Tour what what do you
think about the in general the State of
Affairs in the Chess World you know with
Dingle ran absent with Magnus who like
lost some points lately with hikaro who
show quite good result I mean in general
what is your opinion what's happening
now is someone who is inside of all
this a lot is
changing uh these days um especially the
level of of every top player but even
the players uh one uh I mean one circle
behind like from 2650 let's say to
272 uh everyone's been the opening
preparation has improved drastically
because of computers so that means the
difference in level is starting the Gap
is reducing a bit especially in
classical I think in Rapid and blads
there still uh like quite some
difference um between some
players and
um yeah I has been showing spectacular
results um for the past two years
um well done to him of course it doesn't
change the fact that uh Magnus has been
absolutely dominant for the past uh 12
13 years maybe in classical is less
dominant this year but I wouldn't say
that uh that is a Trend and that uh and
that it will uh keep on forever and I
and for instance this year's the most
impressive player I think has been
Fabiano because he showed the same
performance basically as iar but over
many more
events uh so Fabiano has been doing
great and you know I mean in general I
would call him the second player in the
world for the past 10 years uh there's
no doubt in my
mind um as for at least in classical
chess of course in Rapid and it's
another story uh and as for ding U well
he won this world championship
match uh I think he was dominated
throughout but he found some great
resources and then played extremely well
in the tie breaks uh since then I guess
he's been trying to
recover um because physically so much um
I mean Magnus has spoke spoken about it
soing also has sort of spoken about it
it's he takes t on you uh I do expect to
to see him back in 2024 and you know I
mean he's always been a great player so
again I I expect him to come back at
full
strength no you mentioned that many
young players many players from the 650
to 750 I mean getting uh up uh do you
think someone else in the nearest Future
will cross
to800 who knows probably it might happen
at some point of course uh I didn't even
mention that there were so many like the
generation of course from 1990 and let's
say to
1994 uh with uh closing with Anish has
been absolutely
dominant um then the generation from 95
to 2000 I mean there's been some great
players of course there's Richard
there's uh Duda and some others but uh
it has failed to leave you know
to the expectations compared to to this
1990 and of course now we're seeing the
new generation coming well let's say
from 2002 to
20067 and I mean they have uh great
Pages great uh absolutely great players
uh especially from India but not only
from usbekistan as well and so
on so yeah I mean those guys will uh
likely fight for the top spots in the
next few years do you think somebody can
replace Magnus on the first place on
top it will happen inevitably So like um
you know but for now I wouldn't even
count out U um players from
uh from our generation to to keep
fighting for the next few years um then
of course there's ala who has had a few
tough tournaments lately but is still
the only one of this generation who is
already established as a top player and
will prove this worse in this uh you
know uh huge um tournaments like
singfield cup and so on so you know I
mean I still expect ala to do great as
well yeah and just last question coming
back to grest try to name like three
players from Young Generation who might
participate soon in GCT and will be full
tour players yeah well I
mean it's very possible um I mean hard
to say but I do expect which one but I
do expect someone from India so like
gues or pag uh or boss I don't know if
they'll be playing already next year but
I mean in the next few years that's
certainly almost a guarantee there's of
course Abdu satov and then from the even
younger players you have uh sov
uh with up UNC coming and I mean you
have many others you have Vincent K also
is uh on the verge of 2730 I think so
you know that's quite huge yeah we have
many good FL States for sure yes thank
you so much Maxim for this interview and
all the best of luck for you in both
events yeah thank
[Music]
you